et justement on parle de la situation
économique avec jean marc sylvestre
journaliste et éditorialiste économique
bonjour jean marc sylvestre tout d'abord
pourquoi la france s'en sort-elle plus
mal que le reste de la zone euro doit
l'écouter c'est vrai qu'à france a perdu
13 8% 2 de son pib au deuxième trimestre
c'est l'indicateur qui mesure la
l'accumulation de richesses la création
de richesses dans un pays c'est
historiquement une catastrophe jamais ça
m'est arrivé sauf pendant la dernière
guerre mondiale si bien sûr mais sinon
en mai 68 en 2008 2009 au lendemain des
subprimes ou de lehman brothers
l'effondrement n'avait pas été aussi
brutal
alors c'est gravissime parce que le pipe
je vous le disais c'est l'ensemble des
richesses produites c'est le produit du
travail de tout le monde on a perdu des
ballons de plusieurs années d'activité
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs que les
allemands ou les pays de l'europe alors
alors l'espagne a perdu plus que nous
c'est vrai la grande bretagne aussi mais
nous avons nous chuté dans des
proportions
en gros pour trois raisons la première
c'est à cause du coût filmant un très
stricte
tout s'est arrêté la france s'est mise
dans le coma tout s'est arrêté sauf
quelques secteurs stratégiques la santé
l'alimentaire le digital qui a bien
marché
une autre confinement a été beaucoup
plus strictes que dans les autres pays
et puis la deuxième raison c'est que la
france avait des faiblesses
structurelles corps ont parfois on
ignorait on mettait la poussière sous
dun sous le tapis elles se sont creusés
pendant le confinement nous avions des
entreprises malade pour l'expression de
santé s'est aggravé
nous avions des sujets à risque air
france renault mais aussi beaucoup de
petites entreprises enfin la france
dépend beaucoup de l'étranger ces
importations d'abord et puis son
tourisme aussi c'est la première
industrie française et ces secteurs ont
été complètement fermée puisque les
moyens de communication ont été arrêtés
ils sont pas encore un peu un succès
aujourd'hui alors normalement l'activité
aurait dû reprendre à la sortie
du confinement or le redémarrage est
assez mou parce que la consommation n'a
pas repris c'est bien ça mais la
consommation a rebondi à la sortie du du
confinement il ya eu un petit rattrapage
en mai en juin mais ça s'est calmé en
juillet normal c'est vrai on pouvait
s'attendre à une reprise beaucoup plus
vigoureuse beaucoup plus fort rattrapage
qui aurait entraîné l'activité nous ne
sommes pas revenus ainsi passion normale
en réalité les consommateurs français
sont restés très frileux très prudent
pendant les vacances alors qu'ils
avaient de l'argent à dépenser grâce au
chômage grâce à l'allocation chômage
partiel notamment la majorité des
français ont conservé leur rémunération
mais ils ont stocké cet argent sur des
comptes dépassent le montant accumulé
sur les comptes d'épargné notamment la
caisse d'epargne atteint les 100
milliards d'euros là encore c'est
historique
mais ça mais à cela on pourrait ajouter
aussi ce qui a été accumulée sur les
comptes courants
ça représente environ 400 milliards sur
l'assurance vie qui est aussi largement
de l'argent disponible 1300 milliards au
total on a une somme colossale de 2000
milliards d'argent le total de cet
argent est disponible
il est important mais c'est de l'argent
que les français refusent de consommer
ou d'investir alors pourquoi ont-ils
autant d' épargne de précaution
et bien tout simplement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance ils ont peur du
virus
ils ont peur du chômage l'indicé de la
peur est au plus haut dans ce pays donc
tout le monde se met aux abris et le
gouvernement annonce un plan de 100
milliards d'euros comment imaginer une
relance sans consommation
alors non ne cherchez pas c'est tout le
problème il faudra il faudra de résoudre
le plan de relance va bénéficier
principalement aux entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent redémarrer avec des
investissements avec de réelles des
créations d'emplois terreau la
coalisation industrielle du digital de
la transition écologique
les entreprises peuvent redémarrer parce
qu'elles n'ont pas été cassés
elles n'ont pas été peu l ont pas été
détruite donc les actifs existe les
entreprises vont pouvoir redémarrer
parce que l on continuer de garder
finalement leur structure même les
contrats de travail ont été préservés or
ce qui manque aux entreprises ce sont
des clients ce sont les consommateurs
les clients sont absents ils sont assis
sur leur épargne
on va falloir débloquer reconstruire ce
contrat de confiance qui existe avec le
client avec le consommateur
ça dépend de quoi ça dépend des
conditions sanitaires ça dépend du
climat de sécurité globale qui existent
dans la société or actuellement c'est
quand même pas optimum l'argent est là
l'ambition est là mais le virus rhône et
la sécurité dans les rues dans les
quartiers ne favorise pas la reprise le
problème n'est pas technique il n'est
pas financier pour l'instant il est
politique
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre pour
toutes ces précisions jean marc
sylvestre journaliste et éditorialiste
économique merci beaucoup